the rock is throwing stones Dwayne the
rock Johnson recently took to Instagram
to discuss the box-office performance of
his latest flick Hobson Shaw as of
September 16th 2019 the first ever
spin-off film in the Fast & Furious
franchise has earned more than 740
million dollars worldwide Johnson posted
a screenshot of a deadline article
confirming Hobson's Shah is currently
the best earning non-superhero
non-disney movie of the year but he also
fired shots at someone in the caption
which read assassins quietly played
chess loud clowns played checkers
Thank You audiences worldwide for this
incredible support and massive win very
cool and were grateful for the love one
of the hashtags the actor added was
quote no candy-asses
replacing the e with a clown emoji in
the moment so who was on the receiving
end of his diss that would be none other
than Tyrese Gibson a fast and furious
franchise mainstay with whom Johnson has
been engaged in a drawn-out and often
dramatic view back when Hobson Shah was
first starting to take shape
Johnson was apparently faced with a
decision go forward with that film or
prioritized the 9th Fast & Furious movie
originally slated to hit theaters on
April 19th 2019 according to The
Hollywood Reporter ultimately Johnson
hopped on Hobson Shah and it wasn't long
after the official announcement dropped
that fast 9 was pushed back by almost a
year moving to an April 10th 2020
release date Johnson later noted that he
wouldn't appear in Fast and Furious 9 at
all according to the drive it was an
outcome that Gibson had desperately
hoped wouldn't happen
Gibson publicly begged Johnson not to
move ahead with Hobson Shah writing in a
sense deleted Instagram post in part if
you move forward with that Hobbs movie
you will have purposely ignored the
heart-to-heart moment we had my Sprinter
I don't want to hear from you until you
remember what we talked about fast
family is just that a family we don't
fly solo
the vast nine release date has already
been announced and we can't let our
loyal fans or our loyal fast and furious
fans down on any level from pushing the
date didn't you see how huge the fate of
the Furious was it's because we
announced and kept our release date pro
after Johnson chose Hobbs and Shaw and
fast 9 got delayed tensions between
Gibson and Johnson continued to flare
[Applause]
Gibson blame Johnson for the fast nine
delay slamming him is greedy and
self-centered in an Instagram post that
red imparts congratulations to the rock
and your brother-in-law AKA seven bucks
producing partner for making the fast
and furious franchise about you fast
family right now it's about team Dwayne
Gibson later openly disc Johnson again
on Instagram accusing him of using
steroids and placing blame on the actor
for making the personal troubles he was
dealing with even worse at the time
Gibson called Johnson a clown and a
quote candy ass [ __ ] - thanks Johnson
referenced in his recent social media
post in early August 2019 just a few
days after Hobson Shah opened in
theaters on August 2nd Gibson posted a
screenshot of a news article that noted
the film had posted the lowest opening
weekend for a fast and furious franchise
entry since a 2006 launch of The Fast
and the Furious
Tokyo Drift the now deleted post
featured a caption that read in part
breaking up the family clearly doesn't
have the value that one would assume it
does fast family has more value as the
fast family 180 million dollar global
opening on Hobson Shah is not a win at
this point it doesn't seem like the
back-and-forth bickering between Gibson
and Johnson will stop anytime soon with
Johnson out of fast and furious 9 at
least the pair can avoid some
potentially painfully awkward days on
set check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite action stars are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]